virgin et je romps députée européenne du
rassemblement national et jean philippe
dugoin clément mary dei de mennecy et
vice-président de la région
ile-de-france bonsoir à vous merci
d'être avec nous ce soir en direction
arte france virginie joron doit-on
sortir de cet état d'urgence
bon soit on va écouter déjà un premier
point c'est que cette information que
même parmi les siens est contestée ce
qui prouve vraiment le problème qui lie
actuellement avec ses mesures d'urgence
qui en fait permettent au gouvernement
d'essayer nous à faire affalés plusieurs
pilules on l'a vu très récemment avec
cette volonté de modifier à quelques
mois des élections présidentielles le
scrutin donc un état d'urgence qui
permet tout et n'importe quoi tu nous le
dénonçons depuis un moment
et effectivement nous devons nous faire
valoir nos droits et surtout rester sur
le qui vive parce que ça devient du
n'importe quoi donc il faut en sortir de
cet état d'urgence
oui il faut il pas en sortir parce que
là on voit bien alors je sortir nous
avons des délais on va rester tvd
puisqu'il est prévu jusqu'au mois de
juin
mais ce que je regrette c'est que on
profite de cet état d'urgence pour faire
tout et n'importe quoi comme je vais
préciser à ce moment avec ce projet de
loi
on l'a vu au mois de décembre ou en
catimini ils ont dû enlever un autre
projet de loi où on voulait nous imposer
un passeport vaccinale est porté en
avant une forme de ségrégation entre les
vacciner les non vaccinés
donc oui moi ce que je regrette c'est
avec cet état d'urgence le gouvernement
ne respecte plus la loi et s'arroge des
pouvoirs qui sont antidémocratiques et
liberticide pour nos concitoyens
jean philippe dugand clément al'approche
justement des échéances
tellement de la présidentielle le
maintien de cet état d'urgence est ce
qui peut poser problème
ça c'est un problème qui est le propre
d'un monsieur macron et à son
gouvernement de savoir si ces villes
pose un problème ou par mois je suis
quand même assez frappé de voir on a
aujourd'hui une dizaine de
parlementaires de la majorité qui grosso
modo viennent rejoindre des
interrogations qui ont été celle de
toutes les oppositions à l'assemblée
nationale sur les problématiques posées
par cet état d'urgence c'est à dire
qu'on est sur une urgence alors qu'on
ait des mesures d'exception peux le
comprendre mais l'urgence ça fait un an
maintenant qu'on est dans l'urgence donc
vous pourrez imaginer toutes sortes de
l'urgence on rentrait dans une certaine
forme de normalité
deuxième chose que pose cet état
d'urgence aux problèmes aujourd'hui
majeur c'est qu'il ya aucune discussion
au parlement normalement le garde-fou
c'est le parlement l'état d'urgence
permet des mesures dérogatoires du droit
commun tels que le couvre-feu tels que
des confinement qui soit généraux est
sectorisé délimitation d'ouverture sur
certains magasins sur des universités
mais la réalité c'est qu'on donne une
possibilité au premier ministre au
ministre la santé et au préfet mais sans
aucun débat au parlement pour savoir si
les mesures qui sont prises sont adaptés
ou ne sont pas adaptés et ce qui est
assez terrible c'est que les débats
parlementaires depuis maintenant un an
se limite de la part du ministre de la
santé lorsque les groupes d'opposition
quelquefois viennent essayer d'abord
c'est le débat sur telle ou telle mesure
sur quasiment une mise en jeu ou une
mise en accusation d' irresponsabilité
sanitaires et 7e c'est qu'on ne peut pas
discuter donc on doit je crois
effectivement sortir de cet état non ça
sera pas avant le premier jour puisque
c'est ce qui a été voté même pas par
l'intégralité de la majorité mais par
une partie de la majorité eu des pertes
en ligne au moment des votes mais
maintenant c'est réparé le 1er juin pour
aller
un système normal dans le cadre duquel
s'il doit y avoir des mesures
dérogatoires du droit de droit commun ce
choix de nos chiffres qu'il soit discuté
au parlement qui est l'organe qui
garantit la liberté des citoyens
jean philippe dugoin il le fait que ce
soit justement des membres de la
république en marche qui qui justement
interpellent le premier ministre ça vous
inspire quoi qu on se rend bien compte
qu'il y a ras-le-bol de la population
qui n'en peut plus ceci le deuxième
sujet l'état d'urgence ou les mesures
d'exception un moment c'est le rapport
le ratio entre leurs coûts et leur
efficacité et le coup on a beaucoup
parlé du coût économique avec le fameux
quoi qu'il en coûte du président très
bien c'est une chose
ce qu'aujourd'hui je pense on mésestime
c'est le coût social le coût sociétal le
coût psychique pour beaucoup de nos
compatriotes
on parle souvent des étudiants qui font
partie des plus frappé mais où est ce qu
on place le curseur entre le les mesures
qui sont prises pour contrer la pandémie
et les dégâts que c'est le jure peuvent
causer et aujourd'hui je retiens
ras-le-bol très très fort de la part
d'une partie de la population qui est
nerveusement mentalement épuisé est ce
que disent ces députés c'est courageux
de leur part quand vous êtes dans un
groupe majoritaire d'accepter d'en
sortir d'un doit avoir une voix un petit
peu différente
c'est tout simplement le ressenti que
chacun dans nos communes dans nos
circonscriptions constate au quotidien
virgin et jambon le ras-le-bol de la
population
est ce que c'est un rapport aussi avec
ce côté non justement ce député qui ont
qui sont signataires d'une lettre
adressée à jean castex pour que cette
d'urgence ne dure pas il ya la
démocratie est en péril
bien sûr que le problème c'est que et là
encore déclaré aujourd'hui
macron c'est que on n'a pas de
visibilité on la retient les gens en
suspens les restaurateurs on leur a fait
croire qu'on allait rouvrir en mono
qu'y apprend les a fermés et puis donc
du coup c'est un flou qui est maintenant
inacceptables ça fait presque un an que
nous sommes dans cet état des mesures
concrètes n'ont pas été faites la
création de lits de réanimation
cela n'a pas été fait on maintenant il
ya une campagne de vaccination qui
commençait est pas aisé il ya des
difficultés d'accès on ne sait toujours
pas si même vacciné on va pouvoir quand
même circuler
on va pouvoir parce que là j'ai un
exemple concret les personnes âgées sont
effectivement vaccinées dans les ehpad
mais les personnes qui peuvent aller
voir leurs parents donc toujours pas ce
même accès facilité donc il ya aucune
visibilité
effectivement et je partage ce
ras-le-bol des français parce que nous
aussi on a une fille des campagnes à
venir
on a aussi en boîtier proche de nos
concitoyens et ses limitations d'accès
c'est une citation déplacements sont
insupportables d'autant qu'en plus le
gouvernement joue la junte a joué 20
minutes il n'y a aucune visibilité en
plus un autre scandale
il a aidé financier on voit bien que les
décisions sont prises par des cabinets
privés maquille c'est un scandale
début janvier faut savoir que tous les
jours et heures de n'est pas un
professionnel du mistral à santés
discipline mais c'est celui qui conduit
un cabinet privé donc là aussi ça pose
question est aujourd'hui toute cette
opacité est insupportable alors
l'opacité puisque c'est vrai qu'à des
conseils de défense sanitaire qui
s'enchaînent jean philippe dugoin
clément justement sur les décisions qui
sont prises par exemple par ce cabinet
mckinsey ça ça peut faire penser qu' il
ya des dérives quand même oui c'est ce
qui se passe sous le parlement ni pu
consulter quand le débat n'est plus au
parlement mais un lieu ailleurs alors ça
fait partie des sujets qui ont été
beaucoup évoqué depuis plusieurs mois
c'était le recours à des conseils des
cabinets conseils de l'accusé dans le
plu
célèbre d'entre eux et puis dans celui
du plus de liaisons entre guillemets
dangereuse avec le pouvoir en place
depuis certains morts mais ça n'est pas
le seul et puis c'est aussi la question
du conseil de défense qui glisse
certaine manière avant postes concédés
muls est remplacée par le passe au
parlement
en quoi ça pose un problème d'avoir
recours justement à un cabinet de type
machine sert cabinet d'expertisé
s'interroge par rapport au fait qu'il ya
quand même une administration
ministérielle qui est important selon
ces métiers dans ce travail qu'on est
sur des cabinets privés qui ont pu avoir
par le passé un certain nombre de
contrats avec un certain nombre d'élus
un certain nombre de manques du
gouvernement voir avec potentiellement
le le président au moment de sa
candidature
qu'on est sur des cabinets dont on ne
connaît pas exactement démission et que
sur un sujet qui est un sujet régaliens
on n'est pas sur la question de la
campagne de communication pour
développer le tourisme dans le bas
poitou
on est sur un sujet régalien qui touche
à la santé des procès et on délègue le
manière objectivement assez opaque la
stratégie qui il menait jusqu'où à un
cabinet étranger
c'est ce qui pose problème et le tout
sans débat au parlement encore une fois
on peut en accord ou en désaccord
c'est la démocratie c'est très bien
qu'on soit pas tous d'accord
messieurs démarre il doit faire de
manière constante public au sein des
chambres parlementaires
la virginie jauron oui je partage ce
monsieur
en effet les débats sont importants
parce que le parlement c'est quand même
la représentation des citoyens
et puis avec ce cabinet de ces postes
question c'est effectivement le
financement on voit que ça coûte 2
millions d'euros par mois
il ya eu des départs de entre une somme
à coup dans dans la prise de ce
gouvernement comptera près de 5 millions
d'euros ou effectivement tout une bulle
de cabinets privés
tout autour d'eux me ce qui pose
question si c'est l'accès à nos données
de santé puisque on sait bien que c'est
un contrat a été signé avec microsoft
donc effectivement ça pose question ça
pose débat et
le fait d'avoir écarté les débats
d'avoir écarté finalement la
représentation des citoyens
c'est où qu'on vive autoritaire
effectivement je comprends cette
démarche de ses députés et qui demandent
certainement que ça doit être pire
à l'intérieur ce qui pose problème à ses
députés c'est le le caractère
exceptionnel justement de l'état
d'urgence qui à leurs yeux ne l'est plus
et aussi le principe fondamental des
libertés voilà en toute circonstance
donc il propose d'inscrire dans la
constitution le régime de l'état
d'urgence qu'en pensez vous oui pourquoi
pas par nature l'état d'urgence avait
quelque chose qu'il faut exceptionnel le
problème de l'état d'urgence c'est qu'il
est lui même défini au travers du noir
loin qui d'ailleurs c'est ont jusqu'à la
fin de l'année est ce que l'état
d'urgence le succès au 1er juin mais la
définition comme a été donnée va jusqu'à
la fin de l'année donc y ait cette
discussion au parlement parce que le
problème auquel on est confronté
aujourd'hui l'état d'urgence suite aux
attentats terroristes ou 2015 qui a été
proclamé également pourquoi pas mais
véritablement le prennent le sont
aujourd'hui c'est le fait qu'on est sur
quelque chose qui dure
à partir du moment où c'est dur si
l'urgence si on n'est plus dans
l'exceptionnel et on devrait pouvoir
avoir y compris s'il ya des mesures
d'exception qui s'est justifiée d'un
point de vue sanitaire
on devrait pouvoir avoir quasiment en
permanence ce débat au niveau des deux
chambres parlementaires
il faut ouvrir le débat verger une jambe
certaines présentations
oui parce qu'il ya eu plusieurs points
de dérives comme je les dirai que ce
projet de loi qui a été coté à noël et
qui a eu un dallage donc il faut rester
vigilant et parce qu'effectivement il ya
cette dérive qui permet à ce
gouvernement de vouloir faire passer des
lois sans débat parlementaire
nous sommes comme vous savez nous en
plus nous sommes très bien victime déjà
deux systèmes qui nous écarte de la paix
au parlement avec avec le système vous
connaissez mais effectivement c'est
il faut reprendre je crois le débat il
faut reprendre la main sur le sujet
parce que c'était aussi écoeuré nos
concitoyens envers le système politique
que nous avons en place
alors je sais que proposition de loi
était pour lutter contre l'absentéisme
et je crois que tout ce qui est démontré
à l'heure actuelle puis un an
au contraire hecker les gens et les
éloigne encore plus de la politique est
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire c'est l'envoi
des fours il faut qu'à partir du 1er
juin on cesse déjà il faut commencer à
alléger toutes ces mesures d'exception
puisque me vois bien même le couvre-feu
est lecteurs abandonnent il faut se
poser la question de son utilité
bon s'il faut commencer à se poser les
parcours à toute mesure prise là je vois
qu'ils y sont ils décident de les
restreindre mais je pense
qu'effectivement peut-être avant de
réfléchir sur du court terme pour par
rapport à des territoires précis et et
alléger certaines mesures parce que la
très compliqué avec la circulation des
variantes qui inquiète
il aimait mais là aussi les bars y en a
on nous fait peur avec ces variants un
coup les collections poule et vient
d'affirmer que tu n'en sais rien en fait
j'écoute est tout à leur médecin parce
que c'est vrai que plusieurs même de
discuter sur ce projet mais même le dise
un virus par nature à un marié il va il
va changer il va muter donc forcément il
va s'adapter
la vague de vaccins l'immunité
collective au forcément il va y restera
rien donc il va falloir vivre avec il va
falloir penser à rebondir à alléger
toutes ces mesures pourrait
effectivement parce que des grosses
pressions ces bilans du rapport entre le
bénéfice et le risque est aujourd'hui
bon on voit quand les bilans baisse que
c'est plus ou moins de maîtrise et qui a
les vaccins mine de rien il ya une
campagne qui est fait et donc il faut
vraiment commencer à réfléchir à lever
toutes ces mesures pour pouvoir
reprendre la vie et vivre avec jean
philippa d'hugo clément vous êtes
d'accord en fait sourire l'open c'est
qu'aujourd'hui le gouvernement dispose
de pouvoirs exceptionnels mais sur la
quotité l'application de ces pouvoirs
c'est là il n'y a pas de discussion
et c'est là où justement on devrait
pouvoir avoir cette discussion
on voit maintenant qu'on est quasiment
puis un ordre national et sera compliqué
on les confine dans 17 mars
ça fait pratiquement un an on est sur ce
schéma là et il faut qu'on arrive à
trouver les moyens d'aller vers une vie
quasiment normal y compris si on sait
que le virus si on peut être amené à
devoir vivre avec pendant encore
plusieurs mois en fonction de la vitesse
de la vaccination en fonction des
déclinaisons de variants mais on ne
pourra pas vivre dans ces conditions
d'état d'urgence avec tout ce que ça
implique pour les français pendant
encore de nombreux mois donnons nous les
moyens de vivre normalement
et ça on pourra le faire qu'en décembre
réfléchir et à priori la fin de l'état
d'urgence va presque coïncidé avec une
campagne de vaccination très avancé
selon les prévisions des autorités de
l'exécutif et du gouvernement tout cas
merci à vous jean philippe dugoin
clément maire de mennecy mais rudy de
même si vice-président de la région
ile-de-france et merci à vous la
virginie âge auront députée européenne
du rassemblement national